Vabbè ma ormai stati insieme da più di 4
anni eh Cioè se non ti chiede ancora di
sposarlo c'è qualcosa che non va Non è
che ha un'altra Eh ma non esserne così
sicura cara mia anche Roberta l'anno
scorso diceva No lui non farebbe mai una
cosa del genere lui mi ama troppo
intanto non una Cioè ne aveva diamanti
dico Almeno fate un bambino per
rallegrare un po' la coppia vero Manco
una casa c'hai e tu dici faccio un
bambino dove lo cresco poi a casa di
mamma Eh sì sempre così si dice figli
più avanti poi magari quando decidi di
farli puoi più avere Ma tu quanti anni
hai adesso giovane non lo sai più Sei
proprio inbilico al limite proprio
l'orologio è lo senti ticchettio poi
aspetta Poi se non li vuoi avere io lo
rispetto io la gente che non vuole
essere madre va bene uguale È una
decisione tua ma ricordati che i figli
sono la gioia della vita che arriverà un
giorno in cui tu ti sentirai incompleta
proprio come donna Poi non dire che non
te l'avevo detto